ya es la variante dominante en Estados
Unidos el Centro de Control y Prevención
de Enfermedades declaro este lunes que
73% de los contagios por covid-19 son
por el nuevo linaje la cifra sube a 90 %
en algunos estados este martes el
presidente Joe Biden hablar al respecto
aunque se adelantó que no será para
referirse a un nuevo confinamiento
el presidente ha sido claro en que si
los individuos están vacunados y si
contra el covid-19 la naturaleza
altamente transmisibles de Omicron sus
casos serán más suaves o asintomáticos
seguimos viéndolo y así luego nuestros
expertos que eres 14 veces más propensos
a morir de si no estás vacunado que si
lo estás
registró este lunes la primera muerte
relacionada con Omicron en Estados
Unidos que añadido españa-finlandia y
Líbano en la lista de países a los que
no se recomienda viajar pero la dosis de
refuerzo sigue siendo la verdadera arma
estadounidense contra ohmica
acerca de los estudios clínicos e in
vitro indican que los refuerzos son
fundamentales para reconstruir la
protección las fiestas de fin de año
están lejos de ser normales en este
escenario y Nueva York algunos
residentes parecen estar conscientes de
la necesidad de ciertas medidas
menos etcétera que del TAM así que creo
que eso es algo bueno pero es un poco
más contagiosa y creo que hay una gran
probabilidad de que veamos a mucha gente
inmunocomprometida y de edad avanzada
muriendo eso asusta mucha gente ante
este escenario el alcalde Bill de Blasio
no ha descartado cancelar el tradicional
festejo de fin de año en Times Square